The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK.
So this is Lecture 14,
it's also the lecture
before the exam on
Tuesday evening.
I thought I would just go ahead
and tell you what questions
there are, so you could see.
I haven't filled
in all the numbers,
but this will tell
you, it's a way
of reviewing of
course, to sort of see
the things that we've done.
Which is quite a bit, really.
And also of course topics
that will not be in the exam.
You can see that they're not
in the exam, for example.
Topics from 1.7 on
condition number, or 2.3
on Gram-Schmidt, that I can
speak about a little bit.
So those are the,
only thing I didn't
fill in is the end time there.
So I don't usually
ask four questions,
three is more typical.
So it's a little bit longer
but it's not a difficult exam.
And I never want time to be
the essential ingredient.
So 7:30 to 9 is
the nominal time,
but it would not be a
surprise if you're still
going on after 9
o'clock a little bit.
And I'll try not to, like,
tear a paper away from you.
So, just figure that if you move
along at a reasonable speed,
and so you can bring papers,
the book, anything with you.
And I'm open for questions
now about the exam.
You know where 54-100 is, it's
a classroom unfortunately.
Not a, sometimes we'll have the
top of Walker where you have
a whole table to work
on, that's-- This 54-100,
in the tallest building of MIT
out in the middle of the middle
space out there, is
a large classroom.
So if you kind of spread
out your papers we'll be OK.
It's a pretty big room.
Questions.
And, of course, don't forget
this afternoon in 1-190
rather than here.
So, review is in
1-190, 4 to 5 today.
But if you're not
free at that time
don't feel that you've
missed anything essential.
I thought this would
be the right way
to tell you what the exam is and
guide your preparation for it.
Questions.
Yes, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR STRANG: So these
are four different questions.
So this would be a question
about getting to this matrix
and what it's about,
A transpose C A.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK, I don't
use beam bending for that.
I'm thinking of elastic bar.
Yeah, stretching equation, yeah.
So the stretching equation,
so the first one we ever saw,
the stretching equation, was
just u'', or -u'', equal 1.
And now that allows
a C to sneak in
and that allows a matrix
C to sneak in there,
but I think you'll see what
they should look like, but yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah, yeah.
So this is Section 2.2,
directly out of the book.
M will be the mass matrix, K
will be the stiffness matrix,
yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK.
So, good point to say.
In the very first
section, 1.1, we
gave the name K to a very
special matrix, a specific one.
But then later, now, I'm
using the same letter K
for matrices of that type.
That was the most special,
simplest, completely understood
case, but now I'll use
K for stiffness matrices
and when we're doing finite
elements in a few weeks
again it'll be K.
Yeah, same name, right.
So here you'll want
to create K and M
and know how to deal
with, this was our only
time-dependent thing.
So I guess what
you're seeing here
is not only what time-dependent
equation will be there
but also that I'm
not going in detail
into those trapezoidal
difference methods.
Important as they are, we
can't do everything on the quiz
so I'm really focusing on things
that are central to our course.
Good.
Other questions.
I'm very open for more
questions this afternoon.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Others.
OK.
So, let me, I don't want to
go on and do new material,
because we're focused
on these things.
And this course, the
name of this course
is computational
science and engineering.
And by the way I just
had an email last week
from the Dean of
Engineering, or a bunch of us
did, to say that the
School of Engineering
is establishing Center for
Computational Engineering, CCE.
Several faculty members
there and, like myself
in the School of Science
and the Sloan School
are involved with computation,
and this new center
is going to organize that.
So, it's a good development.
And it's headed by people
in Course 2 and Course 16.
So.
If we're talking about
computations, and I do
have to say something about
how you would actually
do the computations.
And what are the
issues about accuracy.
Speed and accuracy
is what you're
aiming for in the computations.
Of course, the first step
is to know what problem
is it you want to compute.
What do you want to solve,
what's the equation?
That's what we've
been doing all along.
Now, I just take a
little time-out to say,
suppose I have the equation.
When I write K, I'm thinking of
a symmetric, positive definite
or at least
semi-definite matrix.
When I write A I'm thinking
of any general, usually
tall, thin, matrix.
Rectangular.
So that I would need least
squares for this guy, where
straightforward elimination
would work for that one.
And so my first question
is-- Let's take this,
so these are two
topics for today.
This one would come out of 1.7,
that discussion with condition
number.
This one would come out of
2.3, the least squares section.
OK, so if I give
you, and I'm thinking
that the computational
questions emerge
when the systems are large.
So I'm thinking thousands
of unknowns here.
Thousands of equations,
at the least.
OK.
So, and the question is, I
do Gaussian elimination here,
ordinary elimination.
Backslash.
And how accurate is the answer?
And how do you understand?
I mean, the accuracy
of the answer
is going to kind of
depend on two things.
And it's good to separate them.
One is the method you
use, like elimination.
Whatever adjustments
you might make.
Pivoting.
Exchanging rows to
get larger pivots.
All that is in the
algorithm, in the code.
And then the second,
very important aspect,
is the matrix K itself.
Is this a tough problem to solve
whatever method you're using,
or is it a simple problem?
Is the problem ill
conditioned, meeting K
would be like nearly
singular, and then we
would know we had
a tougher problem
to solve, whatever method.
Or is K quite well
conditioned, I
mean the best
condition would be when
all the columns are unit
vectors and all orthogonal
to each other.
Yeah, I mean that would be
the best conditioning of all.
That condition
number would be one
if this K, which, not too likely
is a matrix that I would call
Q. Q, which is going
to show up over here,
in the second problem is,
Q stands for a matrix which
has orthonormal columns.
So, you remember what
orthonormal means.
Ortho is telling
us perpendicular,
that's the key point.
Normal is telling
us that they're
unit vectors, lengths one.
So that's the Q, and then
you might ask what's the R.
And the R is upper triangular.
OK.
So what I said
about this problem,
that there's the method you
use, and also the sensitivity,
the difficulty of the
problem in the first place,
applies just the same here.
There's the method
you use, do you
use A transpose A to
find u hat, this is, now
we're looking for u hat, of
course, the best solution.
Do I use A transpose A?
Well, you would say
of course, what else.
That equation, that
least squares equation
has A transpose A u hat equal A
transpose b, what's the choice?
But, if you're interested
in high accuracy,
and stability,
numerical stability,
maybe you don't go
to A transpose A.
Going to A transpose A kind of
squares the condition number.
You get to an A transpose
A, that'll be our K,
but its condition number
will somehow be squared
and if the problem is
nice, you're OK with that.
But if the problem is delicate?
Now, what does
delicate mean for Au=b?
I'm kind of giving you a
overview of the two problems
before I start on this one.
And then that one.
So with this one
the problem was,
is the matrix nearly singular.
What does that mean?
Does MATLAB tell you,
what does MATLAB tell you
about the matrix?
And that is measured by
the condition number.
What's the issue here is, when
would this be a numerically
difficult, sensitive problem?
Well, the columns of
A are not orthonormal.
If they are, then you're golden.
If the columns of
A are orthonormal,
then you're all set.
So what's the opposite?
Well, the extreme opposite
would be when the columns of A
are dependent.
If the columns of A
are linearly dependent
and some column is a
combination of other columns,
you're in trouble right away.
So that's like big trouble,
that's like K being singular.
Those are the cases.
K singular here,
dependent columns here.
Not full rank.
So, again we're supposing
we're not facing disaster.
Just near disaster.
So we want to know,
is K near the singular
and how to measure
that, and we want
to know what to do
when the columns of A
are independent
but maybe not very.
And that would show up
in a large condition
number for A transpose A. And
this happens all the time;
if you don't set up
your problem well,
your experimental
problem, you can easily
get matrices A, whose columns
are not very independent.
Measured by A transpose A
being close to singular.
Right, everybody
here's got that idea.
If the columns of
A are independent,
A transpose A is non-singular.
In fact, positive definite.
Then, now we're talking about
when we have that property,
but the columns of A
are not very independent
and the matrix A transpose
A is not very invertible.
OK, so that's what
the things are.
And then just to,
because-- Say, on this one,
what's the good thing to do?
The good thing to do is
to call the qr code which
gets its name because it takes
the matrix A and it factors it.
Of course, we all know
that lu is the code here.
It factors K. And qr is
the code that factors
A into a very good guy, an
optimal Q. It couldn't be beat.
And an R, that's upper
triangular, and therefore
in the simplest form you
see exactly what you're
dealing with.
Let me continue this
least squares idea.
Because Q and R are
probably not so familiar.
Maybe the name
Gram-Schmidt is familiar?
How many have seen Gram-Schmidt?
The Gram-Schmidt idea
I'll describe quickly,
but just do those words, do
those guys' names mean anything
to?
Yes, if they do.
Quite a few.
But not all.
OK.
And can I just say,
also Gram-Schmidt
is kind of our name for
getting these two factors.
And you'll see why,
it's very cool to have,
why this is a good first step.
It costs a little
to take that step,
but if you're interested
in safety, take it.
It might cost twice as much
as solving the A transpose
A equation, so you double the
cost by going this safer route.
And double is not a
big deal, usually.
OK.
So, I was going to
say that Gram-Schmidt,
that's the name everybody uses.
But actually their method
is no longer the winner.
And in Section 2.3 and
I'll try to describe
a slightly better method
than the Gram-Schmidt idea
to arrive at Q and R. But let's
suppose you got to Q and R.
Then, what would be the
least squares equation?
A transpose A u hat is
A transpose b, right?
That's the equation
everybody knows.
But now if we have A
factored into Q times R,
let me see how that simplifies.
So now A is QR, and A
transpose, of course,
is R transpose Q
transpose, u hat, and this
is R transpose Q transpose b.
Same equation,
I'm just supposing
that I've got A into
this nice form where
Q has-- where I've taken these
columns that possibly lined up
too close to each other like,
you know, angles of one degree.
And I've got better angles.
I've got-- These columns
of A are too close,
so I spread them out, to columns
of Q that are at 90 degrees.
Orthogonal columns.
Now, what's the deal
with orthogonal columns?
Let me just remember
the main point
about Q. It has
orthogonal columns, right,
and I'll call those
q's. q_1 to q_n.
OK.
And the good deal
is, what happens
when I do Q transpose Q?
So I do q_1 transpose, these
are now rows, to q_n transpose.
q_1 columns to q_n.
And what do I get when I
multiply those matrices?
Q transpose times Q. I get
I. q_1 transpose q_1, that's
the length of q_1
squared is one,
and q_1 is orthogonal
to all the others.
And then q_2, you
see I get the I. q_3,
get an n by n-- I get
the identity matrix.
Q transpose Q is I.
That's the beautiful,
just remember that fact.
And use it right away.
You see where it's
used, Q transpose Q
is I in the middle of that.
So I can just delete that,
I just have R transpose R
and I can even
simplify this further.
What can I do now?
So that's the identity,
so I have R transpose R,
but now I have an R transpose
over here so am I left with?
I'll multiply both sides
by R transpose inverse
and that will lead me to, R
u hat equals, knocking out
our transpose inverse on
both sides, Q transpose b.
Well, that's, our least
squares equation has become
completely easy to solve.
We've got a triangular
matrix here,
I mean it's just
back substitution.
It's just back substitution now,
and a Q transpose b over there.
So a very simple solution for
our equation after the initial
work of A=QR.
OK.
But very safe, Q is a
great matrix to work with.
In fact people-- codes
are written so as
to use orthogonal matrices
Q as often as they can.
Alright, so you had a look
ahead of the computational side
of 2.3, let me come back to
the most basic equations, just
symmetric, positive
definite equations.
Ku=f, and consider OK, how do
we measure whether K is nearly
singular?
OK, let me just
ask that question.
That's the central question.
How to measure,
when is K, which is,
which we're assuming be
symmetric positive definite,
nearly singular?
How to measure that?
How to know whether we're
in any danger or not?
OK.
Well, first you
might think OK, if it
is singular its
determinant is zero.
So why not take its determinant?
Well determinants,
as we've said,
are not a good idea numerically.
First, they're not
fun to compute.
Second, they depend on the
number of unknowns, right?
If I just have
twice the identity,
suppose K is twice
the identity matrix.
You could not get a better
problem than that, right?
If K was twice the
identity matrix
the whole thing's simple.
Or if K is, suppose
K is one millionth
of the identity matrix.
OK, again, that's a
perfect problem, right?
If K is one millionth
of the identity matrix,
well to solve the problem you
just multiply by a million,
you've got the answer.
So those are good.
And we have to have some
measure of bad or good
that tells us those are good.
OK.
So the determinant won't do.
Because the determinant
of 2 I would be two
to the nth, the
size of the matrix.
Or the determinant of
one millionth identity
would be one millionth to the n.
Those are not numbers we want.
What's a better number?
Maybe you could
suggest a better number
to measure how close is the
matrix to being singular.
What would you say?
I think if you think
about it a little,
so what numbers do we know?
Well eigenvalues jumps to mind.
Eigenvalues jumps to mind.
Because this matrix K, being
symmetric positive definite,
has eigenvalues say lambda_1
less than lambda_2, so on.
So on.
Up to, so this is lambda_max
and that's lambda_min,
and they're all positive.
And so what's your idea of
whether the thing's nearly
singular now?
Look at lambda_1, right?
If lambda_1 is near
zero, that somehow
indicates near singular.
So lambda_1 is sort
of a natural test.
Not that I intend
to compute lambda_1,
that would take longer
than solving the system.
But an estimate of
lambda_1 would be enough.
OK.
But my answer is
not just lambda_1.
And why is that?
Because the examples I gave you,
when I had twice the identity,
what would lambda_1
be there in that case?
If my matrix K was beautiful,
twice the identity matrix,
lambda_1 would be two.
All the eigenvalues are two
for the identity matrix.
Now if my matrix was one
millionth of the identity,
again I have a
beautiful problem.
Just as good, just
as beautiful problem.
What's lambda_1 for that one?
One millionth.
It looks not as good, it
looks much more singular,
but that's not really there.
So you could say, we'll
scale your matrix.
And scaling the matrices, in
fact scaling individual rows
and columns to get it,
you might have used,
your unknowns might be
somehow in the wrong units.
So one of the answers is way
big and the second component
is way small.
That's not good.
So scaling is important.
But even then you still
end up with a matrix K,
some eigenvalues and I'll
tell you the condition number.
The condition number of K is the
ratio of this guy to this one.
In other words, two K, or a
million K, or one millionth K,
all have the same
condition number.
Because those problems
are identical problems.
Multiplying by two,
multiplying by a million,
dividing by a million
didn't change reality there.
So if we're in floating
points, it just didn't change.
So the condition
number is going to be
lambda_max over lambda_min.
And this is for symmetric
positive definite matrices.
And MATLAB will print
out that number.
Or print an estimate
for that number;
as I said we don't want
to compute it exactly.
Lambda_max over lambda_min.
That measures how sensitive,
how tough your problem is.
OK.
And then I have to think,
how does that come in, why
is that an appropriate number?
I guess I've tried to
give an instinct for why
it's appropriate, but we can
be pretty specific about it.
In fact, let's do that now.
So what would be the condition
number of twice the identity?
It would be one.
Perfectly conditioned problem.
What would be the
condition, yeah, OK.
What would be the condition
of a diagonal matrix?
Suppose K was the diagonal
matrix two, three, four?
The condition number of
that matrix is two, right?
Lambda_max is sitting there,
lambda_min is sitting there,
the ratio is two.
Of course, any condition
number under 100 or 1000
is no problem.
Roughly the rule of
thumb is that the--
What's the rule of thumb?
I think that maybe
the number of digits
in the condition number,
the number of digits-- Maybe
if the condition number was
1000 you would be taking
a chance that your last three
digits, single precision that
would be three out of
six, three bits-- Somehow
the log of the condition number,
the number of digits in it,
is some measure of the
number of digits you'd lose.
Because you're doing floating
point, of course, here.
That's it, totally well
conditioned matrix.
I wouldn't touch that one.
I mean that's just fine.
But we can figure out-- Here's
the point that I should make.
Because here's the
computational science point.
When this is our special
K, our -1, 2, -1 matrix.
-1, 2, -1 matrix of size
n, the condition number
goes like n squared.
Because we know the
eigenvalues of that matrix,
we could see it.
The largest eigenvalue, when
n is big, say n is 1000.
And we're dealing with our
standard second difference
matrix, the most important
example I could possibly
present.
Then the largest eigenvalues
we actually are there
in Section 1.5, we
didn't do them in detail,
we'll probably come back
to them when we need them.
But the largest
one is about four.
And the smallest
one is pretty small.
The smallest one is
sort of like a sine
squared of a small number.
And so the smallest eigenvalue
is of order 1/n squared.
And then when I do that
ratio of four, lambda_max
is just like four, this
lambda_min is like 1/n squared,
quite small.
That ratio gives
me the n squared.
So there's an indication.
Basically, that's not bad.
That's not bad if n is 1000 in
most engineering problems, that
gives you extremely,
extremely good accuracy.
Condition number of a
million, you could live with.
If n is 100, more typical,
condition number of 10,000
is basically, I think OK.
And I would go with it.
But if the condition number is
way up, then I'd think again,
did I model the problem well.
OK.
Alright.
So that's-- Now I have to tell
you, why is this inappropriate?
How do you look at the error?
So can I write down a way
of approaching this Ku=f?
So this is the first time I've
used the word round-off error.
So in all the calculations,
in all the calculations
that you have to do, to get
to u, those row operations,
and you're doing them
to the right side too,
so all those are floating
point operations in which
small errors are sneaking in.
And it was very unclear,
in the early years,
whether the millions and
millions of operations that you
do, additions, subtractions,
multiplications,
in elimination, do those,
could those add up?
If they don't cancel,
you've got problems, right?
But in general you
would expect somehow
that these are just
round off errors,
you're making them millions
and millions of times,
it would be pretty bad luck,
I mean like Red Sox twelfth
inning bad luck to have
them pile up on you.
So you don't expect that.
Now, what you do solve, so
what you actually compute,
so this is the exact.
This would be the computed.
Let me suppose that the
computed one is sort of a,
there's an error.
I'll call it delta u.
That's our error.
And it's equal to
an f plus delta f.
And this is our round off
error, this is error we make,
and this is error in the answer.
In the final answer.
OK, now I would like to
have an error equation.
An equation for
that error, delta u,
because that's what I'm
trying to get an idea of.
No problem.
If I subtract the exact
equation from this equation,
I have a simple error equation.
So this is my error equation.
OK.
So I want to estimate
the size of that error,
compared to the exact.
You might say, and you
would be right, in saying,
well wait a minute as you do
all these operations you're also
creating errors in K. So I could
have a K plus delta K here,
too.
And actually it wouldn't
be difficult to deal with.
And would certainly be there
in a proper error analysis.
And it wouldn't make
a big difference,
the condition number would
still be the right measure.
So let me concentrate
here on the error
in f, when subtracting
one from the other
gives me this simple
error equation.
So my question is, when is
that error, delta u, big?
When do I get a large error?
And delta f, I'm
not controlling.
I might control the size, but
the details of it I can't know.
So what delta f, now I'll
take worst possible here.
Suppose this is of
some small size,
ten to the minus something,
times some vector of errors,
but I don't know anything
about that vector
and therefore I'd better
take the worst possibility.
What would be the
worst possibility?
What right hand side would
give me the biggest delta u?
Yeah.
Maybe that's the
right question to ask.
So now we're being a
little pessimistic.
We're saying what
right hand side, what
set of errors in
the measurements
or from the calculations would
give me the largest delta u?
Well, so let's see.
I'm thinking the
worst case would
be if delta f was an eigenvector
with the smallest eigenvalue,
right?
If delta f is an eigenvector,
is x_1, the eigenvector that
goes with lambda_1,
the worst case
would be for that to be
the first eigenvector.
That would be the
worst direction.
Of course, it
would be multiplied
by some little number.
Epsilon is every mathematician's
idea of a little number.
OK.
So epsilon x_1, then
what is delta u?
Then the worst delta u is what?
What would be the
solution to that equation?
If the right-hand side was
epsilon and an eigenvector?
This is the whole
point of eigenvectors.
You can tell me what
the solution is.
Is it a multiple of
that eigenvector?
You bet.
If this is an
eigenvector, then I
can put in the same
eigenvector there,
I just have to
scale it properly.
So it'll be just this
side and what do I need?
I think I just need lambda_1.
The worst K inverse can
be is like 1/lambda_1.
Right, if I claim that that's
the answer, if the right hand
side is sort of in
the worst direction,
then the answer is
that same right hand
side divided by lambda_1.
Let me just check.
If I multiply both sides by
K, I have K delta u equals K,
what's K*x_1?
Everybody with me?
What's K*x_1?
Lambda_1*x_1, so the
lambda_1's cancel,
then I got the
epsilon x_1 I want.
So, no surprise.
That's just telling us that
the worst error is an error
in the direction of
the low eigenvector,
and that error gets
amplified by 1/lambda_1.
OK.
So that's brought lambda_1,
lambda_min into it,
in the denominator.
Now, here's another point.
Second point now.
So that would be
the absolute error.
But we saw for those
factors of two and one
millionth and so on, that
really it's the relative error.
So I want to estimate not
the absolute error, delta u,
but the error delta u
relative to u itself.
So that if I scale
the whole problem,
my relative error
wouldn't change.
So, in other words,
what I want to do
is ask in this case,
what's the right hand side?
How big, yeah, I know, I want
to know how small u could be,
right?
I'm shooting for the worst.
The relative error
is the size of u,
maybe I should put it this way.
The relative error is
the size of the error
relative to the size of u.
And I want to know
how big that could be.
OK.
So now I know how big delta u
could be, it could be that big.
But u itself, how
big could u be?
How small could u be, right?
u's in the denominator.
So if I'm trying
to make this big,
I'll try to make that small.
So when is u the smallest?
Over there I said when is delta
u the biggest, now I'm going
to say when is u the smallest?
What f would point
me in the direction
in which u was the smallest?
Got to be the other eigenvector.
This end.
The worst case
would be when this
is in the direction of x_n.
The top eigenvector.
In that case, what is u?
So I'm saying the worst f is
the one that makes u smallest,
and the worst delta f is the
one that makes delta u biggest.
I'm going for the
worst case here,
so if the right side is x_n,
what is u? x_n over lambda_n.
Because when I multiply by K, K
times x_n brings me a lambda_n,
cancel that lambda_n
I get it right.
So there is the smallest u, and
here is the largest delta u.
And the epsilon is coming
from the method we use,
so that's not involved
with the matrix K. So
do you see on there, if
I'm trying to estimate
delta u over u, that's big.
The size of delta u over
this, the size of delta u
over the size of u is what?
Delta u has some epsilon
that measures the machine
number of digits we're keeping,
the machine length, word length
and so on.
This is a unit
vector over lambda_1.
That's delta u over
lambda_1, this u
is in the denominator.
lambda_n-- u is down here,
so the lambda_n flips up.
Do you see it?
By taking the worst case, I've
got the worst relative error.
So that for other methods,
other f's and delta f's, they
won't be the very worst ones.
But here I've written
down what's the worst.
And that's the reason that
this is the condition number.
So I'm speaking about topics
that are there in 1.7, trying
to give you the main point.
The main point is,
look at relative error
because that's the
right thing to look at.
Look at the worst
cases, which are
in the directions of the
top and bottom eigenvectors.
In that case, that relative
error has this condition
number, lambda_n/lambda_1, and
that's the good measure for how
singular the matrix is.
So one millionth of the identity
is not a nearly singular
matrix, because lambda_max
and lambda_min are equal,
that's a perfectly
conditioned matrix.
This matrix has condition
number two, 4/2.
It's quite good.
This matrix is getting worse,
with an n squared in there,
if n is big, and other matrices
could be worse than that.
OK.
So that's my discussion
of condition numbers.
I'll add one more thing.
These eigenvalues
were a good measure
when my matrix was
symmetric positive definite.
If I have a matrix
that I would never
call K, a matrix like one, one,
zero and a million, OK, that,
I would never write K for that.
I would shoot myself
first before writing K.
So what are the
eigenvalues lambda_min
and lambda_max for that matrix?
Are you up now on eigenvalues?
We haven't done a
lot of eigenvalues
but triangular matrices
are really easy.
The eigenvalues of
that matrix are?
One and one.
The condition number should
not be 1/1, that would be bad.
So instead, if
this was my matrix
and I wanted to know
its condition number,
what would I do?
How would I define the
condition number of A?
You know what I
do whenever I have
a matrix that is not symmetric.
I get to a symmetric matrix
by forming A transpose A,
I get a K, I take
its condition number
by my formula, which I
like in a symmetric case,
and then I would
take the square root.
So that would be a
pretty big number.
For this, for that matrix A, the
condition number of that matrix
A is up around 10^6.
The condition number of that
matrix is up around 10^6 even
though its eigenvalues are one
and one because when I form A
transpose A, those eigenvalues
will jump all over.
And then probably this thing
will have eigenvalues way up
and the condition
number will be high.
OK.
So that's a little, you'll
meet condition number.
MATLAB shows it, and you
naturally wonder what is this?
Well, if it's a positive
definite matrix,
it's just the ratio
lambda_max to lambda_min
and it tells you
as it gets bigger
that means the matrix
is tougher to work with.
OK.
We have just five minutes left
to say a few words about QR.
OK, can I do that in
just a few minutes?
And much more is in the codes.
OK, what's the deal with QR?
I'm starting with a
matrix A. Let's make
it two by two, a two by two.
OK, it's got a
couple of columns.
Can I draw them?
So it's got a column there,
that's its first column
and it's got another
column there,
maybe that's not a very
well conditioned matrix.
Those are the columns of
A. Plotted in the plane,
two-space.
OK, so now the Gram-Schmidt
idea is: out of those columns,
get orthonormal columns.
Get from A to Q. So the
Gram-Schmidt idea is, out
of these two vectors, two axes
that are not at 90 degrees,
produce vectors that
are at 90 degrees.
Actually, you can guess
how you're going to do it.
Let me say, OK I'll settle
for that direction, that
can be my first direction, q_1.
What should be q_2?
If that direction is
the right one for q_1
I say OK I'll settle for
that, what's the q_2 guy?
Well, what am I going to do?
I mean, Gram thought of it
and Schmidt thought of it.
Schmidt was a little
later, but it wasn't,
like that hard to think of it.
What do you do here?
Well, we know how
to do projections
from this least squares.
What am I looking for?
Subtract off the
projection, right.
Take the projection
and subtract it off
and be left with the component
that's perpendicular.
So this will be the q_1
direction and this will be,
this guy e, what we
called e, would tell me
the q_2 direction.
And then we could make
those into unit vectors
and we'd be golden.
And if we did that we would
discover that the original a_1,
a_2 and a_1, so this is
the original first column,
and the original second
column, would be the good q_1
and the good q_2 times some
matrix R. So here's our A=QR.
It's your chance to see this
second major factorization
of linear algebra.
LU being the first,
QR being the second.
So what's up?
Well, compare first columns.
First columns, I didn't
change direction.
So all I have is here is
some scaling r_(1,1), zero.
Some number times q_1 is a_1.
That direction was fine.
The second direction, q_2 and
a_2, those involve also a_1.
So there's an r_(1,2)
and an r_(2,2) there.
The point was, this
came out triangular.
And that's what
makes things good.
It came out triangular
because of the order
that Gram and Schmidt worked.
Gram and Schmidt
settled the first one
in the first direction.
Then they settled the first two
in the first two directions.
If we were in three
dimensions, there'd
be an a_3 somewhere here,
coming out of the board.
And then the q_3 would come
straight out of the board.
Right?
If you just see that you've got
Gram-Schmidt completely. a_1
is there.
So is q_1. a_2 is there.
I'm in the board still, in
the plane of a_1 and a_2,
is the plane of q_1 and q_2, I'm
just getting right angles in.
a_3, the third column in
a three by three case,
is coming out at some angle.
I want q_3 to come out
at a 90 degree angle.
So that q_3 will involve some
combination of all the a's.
So if it was three
by three, this
would grow to q_1, q_2, q_3,
and this would then have
three guys in its third column.
But maybe you see that picture.
So that's what
Gram-Schmidt achieves.
And I just can't
let time run out
without saying that this
is a pretty good way.
Actually, nobody thought there
was a better one for centuries.
But then a guy named
Householder came up
with a different way, and a
numerically little better way.
Numerically a little better way.
So this is the Gram-Schmidt way.
Can I just put
those words up here?
So there's the Gram-Schmidt,
the classical Gram-Schmidt idea,
which was what I described, was
the easy one, easy to describe.
And then there's a method
called Householder, just named
after him, that
MATLAB would follow.
That every good qr code now
uses Householder matrices.
It achieves the same results.
And if I had a
little bit more time
I could draw a picture
of what it does.
But there you go.
So that's my lecture
on, my quick lecture
on numerical linear algebra.
These two essential points and
I'll see you this afternoon.
Let me bring those quiz
questions down again,
for any discussion
about the quiz.